thanks to endo Chino for keeping legal
eagle in the air and helping me look fly
humans have been jetting off into space
since April 12 1961 when Russian
lieutenant Yuri Gagarin became the first
human to orbit the earth Alan Shepard
became the first American to enter space
less than a month later yes that's right
the Russians beat us to space by less
than a month but who's counting we
didn't want to be first in space anyway
it's cold and it's dark up there human
space travel is just a couple of years
shy of celebrating its 60th birthday
which means 60 years of weightlessness
freeze-dried food and figuring out how
to use the bathroom without any gravity
however despite more than 50 years of
humans traveling to and living in space
nASA has never had to address the issue
of space pirates no I'm just kidding
space crime but space crime is really
crazy and interesting to what happens
when a crime is committed in space who
has jurisdiction who are the space
police and where is space jail these are
the questions we're going to answer
today
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer and today we are dealing with
potentially the first case of space
crime summer warden a former Air Force
intelligence officer has accused her ex
spouse and McLane a decorated NASA
astronaut of identity theft and improper
access to private financial records when
warden became suspicious of McLane she
asked her bank to trace the location of
any computers that had recently accessed
her bank account using her own login
credentials one of those computers it
turned out was in outer space aboard the
International Space Station
acknowledging that she had indeed
accessed wardens account while in outer
space McLane defended her actions and
claimed that she was merely taking care
of the couple's intermingled finances
nonetheless warden filed a complaint
with the Federal Trade Commission and
her family filed yet another complaint
with NASA's Office of Inspector General
both could be historic in that they
contained the first allegation of
criminal wrongdoing in space so let's
talk about the history of space law the
treaty on principles governing the
activities of States in the exploration
and use of outer space including the
moon and other celestial bodies or the
Outer Space Treaty as it is more
commonly known was entered into by a
hundred and five different parties in
1967 the treaty was essentially the
Magna Carta of space law it established
general principles for the International
use of an exploration of space favored
commercial activities in space and
sought to ensure that the exploration of
outer space could be conducted only for
the benefit of all countries article 6
of the Outer Space Treaty also
emphasized that all nations would quote
bare international responsibility for
national activities in space whether
these activities were carried out by
governmental or private parties since
entering into this international
agreement the United States has
substantially developed its own national
space law most recently the extensive US
space laws were recodified in 2010 in
title 51 of the u.s. code which was
enacted to transfer a number of statutes
dealing with national space programs
into a single place in the United States
Code while title 51 addresses a number
of space related areas it does not
discuss criminal acts in space title 51
does however contain a blanket statement
which presumably forbids any sort of
like Timoney quote this civil space
station may be used only for peaceful
purposes 51 USC section seven zero nine
zero one but what about the
International Space Station the
International Space Station was placed
into orbit in 1984 by the United States
and other nations were invited to
participate in its development and use
in order to facilitate cooperation among
the participating nations Canada the
European partner States Japan Russia and
United States signed the agreement
concerning cooperation on the
International Space Station in 1998
article 22 of the agreement also
outlined criminal jurisdiction aboard
the ISS and determined that each
participating nation quote may exercise
criminal jurisdiction over personnel in
or on any flight element who are their
respective nationals but what actually
happens when a crime is committed on
board the ISS to date were still not
entirely sure but in discussing criminal
jurisdiction in space many scholars have
equated intergalactic crimes with those
committed in Antarctica or at sea in an
attempt to consider what actual
development space law would look like
and of course to avoid common pitfalls
by way of analogy the antarctic treaty
was signed in 1959 by 12 nations whose
scientists had been working on the
continent to date there are a total of
54 parties to that particular treaty
similarly to the respective
jurisdictional rules which govern the
international space station
the antarctic treaty provides that quote
observers scientific personnel and
members of the staffs accompanying any
such persons shall be subject only to
the jurisdiction of the contracting
party of which they are nationals and
respect of all acts or omissions
occurring while they are in Antarctica
for the purpose of exercising their
functions so if you are a u.s. national
doing research in Antarctica the treaty
seems to imply that you are governed by
the rules of the United States while you
are domiciled in Antarctica and by
analogy if you're in the ISS and you
commit a crime you're governed by the
laws of the United States still the
drafters of the Antarctic Treaty left a
lot of questions unanswered and when in
2000 an Australian astrophysicists died
in the South Pole the nations involved
were unsure
how to confront the fact that he was
likely poisoned after dr. Marx
unfortunately passed away in autopsy was
performed and methanol was found in his
system for those of you who don't have
advanced degrees in toxicology which I
will assume is most of you including
myself methanol is a colorless liquid
that smells a lot like ethanol otherwise
known as alcohol but that is far more
toxic so the question remained did dr.
Marx knowingly ingest a highly toxic
substance or was he poisoned the United
States had an interest in investigating
the deaths since Marx died on a US base
and was an employee of an American
contractor New Zealand maintained its
own interest in investigating Marc's
death since it considered the location
of the US base to fall within its own
territorial claim one officer from New
Zealand who handled the case stated that
he could not rule out that the
scientists demise was the direct result
of the act of another person in the base
however despite those suspicions
unresolved jurisdictional questions
competing jurisdictional claims and
conflicting interests prevented anyone
from ever getting to the bottom of dr.
marks death to this day no one knows if
he died by murder-suicide or unfortunate
accident in a similar way international
waters pose similar jurisdictional
questions and conflicts with those
raised in Antarctica and in space maybe
at some point this will have to be an
additional video because if I had a
nickel for every time a legal eagle
asked me to cover maritime law and the
law of the high seas I would be a very
very rich man
at the United Nations conference on the
law of the sea held in 1958 certain
provisions were adopted to regulate
activities in international waters
articles 5 & 6 respectively state that
quote ships have the nationality of the
state whose flag they are entitled to
fly in particular the state must
effectively exercise its jurisdiction
and control and administrative technical
and social matters over ships flying its
flag and quote ships shall sail that's
so hard to say under the flag of one
state only and shall be subject to
exclusive jurisdiction on the high seas
oh I'm so glad I was able to say that
correctly a fugitive or criminal sailing
on a ship in international waters is
therefore subject to the laws and
regulations of whatever [ __ ]
the vessel is registered to the United
States can also exercise special
jurisdiction in international waters
such as when quote any place outside the
jurisdiction of any nation with respect
to an offense by or against a national
of the United States end quote is
involved despite the uncertainty that
still surrounds space law however many
say that with the onset of space tourism
we'll soon have no choice but to expand
the laws that govern the International
Space Station and frankly that's how our
law was created in the first place
American law is a subset of English
common law which means that the law was
created basically as judges went along
they got a new case and when there were
new facts that had to be adjudicated for
the first time they just kind of made it
up as they went in contrast to a lot of
these civil law societies in Europe
where the law is codified and judges
just simply follow that and they never
have discretion in terms of creating new
common law on their own and the funny
thing is that when you're in law school
you read a ton of railroad cases because
in the 18th and 19th centuries trains
were the newfangled technology of the
day and required courts to wrestle with
new legal principles to deal with new
legal situation so really when you think
about it rocket ships and International
Space Station's are just the trains of
today without wheels in space and as
Mark sonned all of the global space law
Center said the more we go out there and
spend time out there all the things that
we do here are going to happen in space
since warden and her family filed their
complaints against McLain and
investigators specializing in criminal
cases with NASA's Office of Inspector
General has begun to look into the
issues surrounding these novel
circumstances while no charges have been
filed as seemingly trivial domestic
dispute could get the ball rolling and
push the US and presumably other space
powers to take a hard look at their
interstellar criminal laws or lack
thereof you know before we know it
everything that happens down here on
earth will eventually happen in space
and while that may eventually mean
shopping on the moon and yoga on Mars
it could also very well mean crime
that's out of this world now if you go
into space you'll need a spacesuit but
if you're back here on earth you need an
actual suit if you're looking for a
custom slim
cut suit that is shockingly affordable I
can't recommend Indo Chino highly enough
no Gino by now you guys know the drill I
love my Indo Chino suits and I
negotiated a special deal for legal
eagles all of my suits are now custom
made by indochina including this grade 2
button that I'm wearing right now which
was custom made just for me see the
secret to a great suit is all about the
fit I'm a reasonably athletic guy and I
can never buy suits off the rack because
they just simply never fit right if the
shoulders fit then the waist is way too
small it either doesn't fit or it costs
a ton to have a tailor fix it but with
Indo Chino you can send in your
measurements online or you can go to one
of their stores and have a stylist take
your measurements for you for me I made
an appointment went to the store in
person had a stylist work with me for
over 90 minutes when I went in for the
first time my personal stylist Andrew
took my measurements and a couple of
weeks later I got the best fitting suit
of my entire life
it was perfect right out of the box and
if it hadn't been they would have
tailored it for me until it was perfect
in no chena will make you a fully custom
tailored suit specifically for you for
less than $400 and the best part is they
still use the best materials like super
140 s wool in fact I asked Indo Chino to
give legal eagles specifically the best
deal possible and they're giving you
guys the exclusive ability to buy any
premium suit for 359 that is the best
deal you will find anywhere on the
internet I will never get an
off-the-rack suit again and once you try
it believe me neither will you legal
eagles can get any premium Indo Chino
suit for just 359 when you enter the
promo code legal eagle at checkout or
use the link in the description clicking
on the link really helps out this
channel that's Indo Chino com promo code
legal eagle for the best custom suit of
your entire life so do you agree with my
analysis are you worried about space
crime or do you think the current law is
already deal with it leave your
objections in the comments and check out
this playlist over here for all of my
other real law reviews where we cover
all of legal topics of the day
where I will see you in court